said Thank You alessia and Marta for
inviting me to this the issue of the
rise of China is occupying the American
political imagination and strategists
and the business community a great deal
whether the rise of China is a threat to
the interests of the United States or
whether it need not be a threat and we
should accommodate to the rise of China
to some extent that debate is sharpened
here by two things one is that that we
take a lot of credit for the rise of
China now that may seem either
blindingly obvious or terribly
controversial but you know when Nixon
visited China and launched the policy of
engagement as we call it he articulated
a strategy of bringing China into the
world of nations and the idea that the
prosperity and stability of China were
in the interests of the United States so
at that time China was reviewed and I
think correctly the US view China's of
revolutionary power that's threatened
the order the international order and
Nixon's idea was we will engage the
Chinese we will entice them with the
material benefits of being part of the
world order that the United States
dominated and they will get rich and
they will become pro stability and all
that happened china became rich and and
I think China has joined you know the
world trade organization as participates
actively in the UN it participates in
the six-party talks it doesn't line up a
hundred percent with the United States
on most issues neither do most of our
other allies for example France line up
one hundred percent with the United
States but China has definitely joined
the international system economically
and politically and diplomatically in a
large way so engagement
worked it was successful in this regard
but as alessia mentioned it hasn't led
so far to China becoming a democracy and
part of the American strategic vision of
the world is that the u.s. is more
secure when other major countries are
democracies we have a substantial
democracy promotion industry in
Washington DC I myself am a member of
the board of an organization called the
National Endowment for democracy which
spends 100 over 100 million dollars each
year promoting that the Congress
appropriates to promote democracy in
various countries including China so the
failure of China to democratize is a big
disappointment strategic disappointment
so forth for the United States and also
the sort of second stage of its
prosperity when it was becoming
prosperous and was settling down and
joining international regimes and
joining the copyright you know
intellectual property right regime and
passing laws that American lawyers said
they needed to pass in order to allow
Western investment and song that was
China coming into alignment with
American wishes and American systems but
now that its wealth is continuing to
increase so massively the question
arises whether its strategic ambitions
will also increase and that will
challenge the u.s. so so this the rise
of China not quite being what American
strategy had envisioned going beyond it
in some respects economically and not
coming all the way up to the vision
politically and then this has
intersected with the recent less decade
or so if China's very dramatic rise has
intersected with
the deterioration of this post Cold War
vision of the United States as the sole
superpower and George W Bush published
in 2002 @ paper called the national
security strategy of the United States
which said that it is the security
strategy of the United States dissuade
any other power from even trying to
develop a status as a pure competitor of
the United States I mean it's hard to if
you don't already know that this
document was published in 2002 it may
seem incredible now in 2011 to realize
that it was published at that time but
the idea was we will be so massively
powerful that any other country China
Russia looking at us will just say it
isn't worth competing well that sense of
the overweening power has gradually
dissipated in the United States for many
reasons that you know so that we now
have a robust debate going on here about
decline ism whether the United States is
in decline so the rise of China
intersects with a moment in the American
consciousness where we're thinking about
ourselves as in decline which has been
really i think sharply exacerbated by
the partisan gridlock in Washington the
proud of view of the Republicans and the
house stymieing every policy initiative
by the president and the president not
being able so far to find a way not
seeming to adopt a strong posture either
toward this has exacerbated the American
sense of decline so with respect to
China it's given rise to this debate and
I reviewed I I guess have you read
things that were you think they've read
those things that we handed out but I
submitted
for you to look at a book review that I
wrote of the Friedberg and Kissinger
reviews where they're the Friedberg is a
very good statement of the China threat
perspective and the Kissinger one is a
and sort of confusing really but in the
end of the day I think influential if
not clearly written statement for an
accommodationist posture toward China
that the rise of China is something we
have to accept and come to terms with
and friedberg suggests we have to find
some way to more strongly resist it so
this is an active debate it's it's it
plays out in Washington for example now
in the struggle over this currency bill
that's going through the Senate or maybe
passed the Senate I'm not sure if it has
yet passed it which is a bill to set up
a mechanism and theory to sanction China
if it doesn't lower the value of its
currency fast enough for the United
States so that there's been also a
debate in Washington over the
president's approved arms sales package
to Taiwan the president approved the
sale of some packages to modify Taiwan's
f-16 fighter aircraft but he did not
make a decision so far anyway to sell
them new models of the f16 so he's been
attacked by some people in Congress and
elsewhere in Washington for being afraid
to provoke the Chinese by selling Taiwan
the weapons that we ought to sell them
so the in this in the policy-making
circle as well so that the debates over
the Taiwan arms sale and over the
currency issue or sort of public
political manifestations of the China
debate they're dramatized
their political show but in the private
policy making circles in Washington
there also is a lot of debate over
strategy issues toward China how to
counter Chinese aggressive naval
patrolling in the South China Sea what
what posture to take on Taiwan arms
sales packages to Taiwan how the US
should defend or what role it should
play in the territorial dispute between
China and Japan so in many places in the
American political system also in the
media this issue of China's being vetted
and debated although not yet in a big
way in the presidential campaign because
right now we have the Republic the whole
presidential campaign is the Republican
primary and for the Republicans the
China issue well there was an article in
yesterday or today or New York Times
saying so far foreign policy has not
really played a role in the Republican
primary campaign but when we get to the
real campaign where Obama will be the
Democratic candidate it's I can't be
sure but I wouldn't be surprised if the
issue of China came up with the
Republican candidate attacking obama for
being soft on china and being
intimidated by china and so on so i want
it so that's a little briefing on the
china issue as it stands now in the
American political debate and I want to
say something because I'm chiefly a
China specialist I often tell people
people will say what do you do I say I'm
a political scientist and they say well
what's who's going to win the election
campaign I don't understand politics is
too complicated for me i only understand
something simple like Chinese politics
so I want to talk a little bit about how
I actually see the rise of China and I
teach a course on Chinese foreign policy
so I talk
about it from a Chinese point of view I
try to develop for the students and
understanding of the drivers of Chinese
policymaking we see the policies
happening we see though they vote in the
UN we see there I understand this
morning you heard from dan rosen we see
there and investments in the US and in
Latin America Africa and around the
world and in Europe we see their arms
build-up but what is driving these
policies and I develop two main points
in the course that I want to share with
you that have a common theme about
China's so far up until the present at
least relative vulnerability in the
international system so we see China is
this very very strong expanding power
and those facts are there but I want to
bring in the two big elements of
vulnerability in the Chinese security
situation as they see it and I think
they see it accurately in large part the
first one is geo strategic that is to
say where China is on the map the
neighborhood that it's in the setup of
China itself so China's of course
because you know I don't need a
powerpoint to make this point big
country with a very large population and
I'm sure you also know but you may not
dwell on this point as much as somebody
like me would do because I study it that
a large part of this Chinese territory
is controlled in securely by the regime
in Beijing it's very different from
France or the United States or other
countries that were familiar with where
the government's control over the people
and the territory is essentially
uncontested in China that's not the case
most ninety-four percent of the popular
consists of these ethnic what they're
called haan haan in other words the
Chinese people that we think of as
Chinese live chiefly along the coast on
a sort of 600 mile band along the coast
the huge cities Shanghai you know
Beijing tangent Shanghai and all down to
Guangzhou and those populations are in
the midst of tremendous social stress as
a result of very fast economic growth
very fast migration from the countryside
into the city's very fast social and
cultural change and as a result their
demands are constantly rising there are
many many demonstrations many issues
over land seizure over pollution over
corruption so that the regime's control
over the society is always on a kind of
tight rope and the government is very
nervous about that and uses many methods
to control it propaganda paying off
dissatisfied groups and a very heavy
police presence internet police
political police and so on so that right
there they're much more insecure when we
have demonstrations on wall street or
you know tea party demonstrations in
Washington it really doesn't threaten
the survival of the regime in the United
States and in China the regime believes
that it's survival is on the line
because of social change and I think
that that it is true that the written
regime survival is on the line and it
could collapse then the huge amount of
Chinese territory Shin John this huge
province in the north west tibet this
huge area also in the west which
includes not only the tibetan autonomous
region that we see on the map but areas
around that that are populated also by
Tibetan ethnic Tibetan people are the
dominant populations in these areas are
really not loyal to the People's
Republic of China they are very
dissatisfied they really don't have a
military or political capability to
break away and establish independence
but they are dissatisfied occasionally
outbreaks of disorders in these regions
and each of those areas has helpers
outside of China there are we gong
people living in Central Asia living in
Germany living in Turkey in Washington
DC there Tibetans in India there's a
Tibetan over you know Tibet I think the
Tibet movement the Dalai Lama is very
popular in France he's popular in the
United States are cozy met with the
Dalai Lama this presents a threat to the
Chinese control of their own territory
it's chiefly Tibet and Xinjiang with the
Mongol people ethnic people in a part of
China inner mongolian Autonomous Region
also are dissatisfied and Taiwan which
from the Chinese point of view is a very
key security Bastion that they must
control is not under their control and
shows no near-term sign of coming under
control Hong Kong which is you know
fairly secure places nonetheless a place
which is difficult for peking beijing to
completely control because of the
arrangement there where it has its own
system and it has a free press and so on
so just within the borders of china as
the chinese see it either including
taiwan they have tremendous security
issues that are not faced by most other
modern states in the international
system maybe russia has that kind of
problem and then the bordering countries
around china are present a long menu of
difficult security issues
then you have Russia which is a huge
country that has always been very
suspicious and paranoid about China you
have Japan which is a very very powerful
country I think we tend to underestimate
the power of the Japanese military in
its technological sophistication which
is very suspicious of China Korea which
you know is a large country 80 million
people the two Koreas together with a
very large army that wants to be
independent of any outside force Vietnam
which is the country that doesn't like
the Chinese India which is the country
that doesn't like the Chinese and your
surrett and big countries that don't
like China now if today we say well
those problems are not severe because
China and Russia are allies in China
North Korea allies in China and South
Korea have tremendous trade in China has
huge investments in Vietnam and Chinese
trade with India is growing all those
things are true but they are not natural
geostrategic facts these are the result
of in various ways of Beijing's policy
efforts and there's the fragility to all
of those relationships because the
geostrategic reality is one of jealousy
and again a country like the United
States doesn't face that you know
neighbors are Canada and Mexico they are
not countries on a scale to threaten us
or with a geostrategic reason to
threaten us France is in the EU I mean
it used to France used to be in a
situation in which it was surrounded by
similar enemies but after World War two
after the creation of the EU after the
development of European civilization
after all of these circumstances you
have a situation in which war with
France's immediate
neighbours is truly unthinkable China is
not in that situation we could spend a
long long time trying to compare why and
it's not necessarily impossible then in
a hundred years from now there could be
something like an Asian security
community but those conditions are far
from ripe at the present time and then
looking beyond the borders of the region
around China which is a large region out
to Latin America the Middle East Africa
and Europe and so forth China finds
itself certainly adds a major power
today but not as a power that can really
defend it with military means or
political influence its interests in
these farther regions China has
increasing dependency on this farther
ring of the world the parts of the world
farther that are beyond its immediate
periphery it has increasing stakes in
those areas it depends on them for oil
for copper for iron for soybeans for
profits for markets and yet it really
doesn't have and a military or a
dominating political capability to
defend those interests in the way that
the United States has and I think that
the European powers have in a selective
way so France has the capability you
know to mount force against Libya along
with Britain and the United States and
France has the capability to go into
other parts of Africa if it needs to do
so the Western powers jointly have the
capability to dominate the Middle East
still and to protect our oil supplies
there in the US now we're not doing that
every day of the week that that
capability is part of the picture in
China doesn't have it so the my first
point about China then is that
has a very deep geostrategic insecurity
that is rooted in geography and the
second point is that it has designed a
strategy to get out of that insecurity
that depends upon interdependence it is
no longer a naught ARCIC economy as you
people though very very well better than
I do the strategy of developing security
through autarky basically failed under
Mao and dung Xiaoping embarked on a
strategy of achieving security through
interdependence and that interdependence
is very very deep and constraining for
China we all live all of the wealthy
countries in the world live in a world
of interdependence India does certainly
all the European countries do in the
United States does but the the ways in
which that interdependence constrains
different countries is probably
different it varies but it is very
constraining on all of them and I think
the primary point I want to make is not
a difference in how interdependence
constrains wealthy countries but the
fact that it constrains China a great
deal I was recently talking to one of my
Chinese friends who's an expert on such
things and we were talking about the
renminbi the Chinese currency the
Chinese dollar the yen which is such a
big issue in Washington and he was
telling me the following things that I
think are kind of illustrative of
interdependence in night in 2005 which
is very recently the Chinese government
made a decision to unpick gradually
unpaid
renmin be the yen from the dollar it had
been fixed by the government they made
that decision for several reasons one
was that it was a WTO obligation they
had entered the WTO excuse me in 2001
and put off this decision until they
felt that they needed to do it a second
reason was that there they were in a
relatively strong economic position so
they could start doing it a third reason
was that it is a long term strategy of
the Chinese government and this is very
public to make the UN eventually into an
international reserve currency and enjoy
all the many benefits that come from
that and that requires a gradual process
of unpacking it and putting it into the
free market and the fourth reason that
they did it was to as part of a strategy
to develop domestic demand they knew
that they needed to develop domestic
demand as a driver for economic growth
which is the same thing that's argued by
the pundits in Washington the Chinese
know that and they agree but it's a
question of the howl Ong it takes to
make that true transition that will give
them more security will also give in
terms of of not dependent not being as
dependent on foreign markets to drive
economic growth end by raising the
living standards of the people so they
began to unpack the UN and it was at
first 8.27 it's now gone to 6.36 that is
6.36 yen to the US dollar which from a
chinese point of view is fairly rapid no
change when you're steering a ship you
know 1.3 billion people and all these
changes have an impact on domestic
prices and on the whole domestic economy
and jobs and they're moving at the pace
that they can move to about 450 25 UN
per dollar and that's the target but it
will take quite a bit of time and he
pointed out to me that the recent so
this is interesting a recent economic
crisis in the
Rose own you guys probably know all this
because you're in the business world
that this came as a an interesting
insight to me has driven up the value of
the dollar people are fleeing to the
dollar as people flee to the dollar the
Chinese have difficulty holding the the
dollar strengthens and it's hard for the
Chinese to maintain the current 6.36
exchange rate it tends to revalue to go
higher than 6.36 which is the wrong
direction for them and so they're
fighting very hard right now to keep it
from increasing in value while in
Washington in the Senate they're being
attacked for not decreasing revaluing
the value of the renminbi faster than
they are so this is it may be small but
I mean currently very timely example of
this interdependence of the global
markets that the Chinese policymakers
have to deal with and of course they're
inter interdependent in so many other
ways so I present this to my class about
these two big facts of Chinese foreign
policy now the what does that mean for
the China threat you know the Kissinger
friedberg debate and that I like to
divide it up into two parts now and the
future because you know we all we don't
know the future so we have to separate
that out and make it a subject of
speculation but we all we know is now
and I think what we can say about now is
that now the Chinese rise of China has
not yet presented what I would call a
threat now it depends on your definition
of the word threat certainly the rise of
China or any development in the
international system is a mix of maybe
not any development but most
developments in the international system
present somebody like the United States
or any other
with a mix of benefit and loss but it
seems to me that up until today or as of
today that the rise of China is
presented more benefit than lost to the
US this is a u.s. centered analysis but
you can make the same analysis probably
for Europe so yes the Chinese are buying
up properties in the u.s. they're
causing adjustment in the u.s. job
market they're acquiring commodities
around the world and so on but
economically there are so many ways in
which the rise of China has benefited
the u.s. the way in which they've
provided low you know raised our
standard of living by providing low-cost
high-quality consumer products their
investments here are good for our
economy their purchase of Treasury bonds
is good for our economy many of the
things that they do are good for our
economy and we are interdependent with
them in that way militarily I think that
we are far from being threatened at this
point by China we have the u.s. rings
China with bases we have faces in Korea
Japan we have a military relationship
not bases with Taiwan we have military
cooperation with the Philippines with
Vietnam with Singapore with Indonesia we
have military cooperation with with
India we have bases in Afghanistan we
have bases in some Central Asian
countries they are surrounded by our
military forces it's true that the
Chinese have acquired certain
capabilities that make would make it
harder for the US military in any
pitched battle that might break out
which conceivably could break out over I
don't expect it to be but conceivably
over the issue of Taiwan but I think the
u.s. at this point remains far in
advance of Chinese technology in terms
of soft power you know the charm of the
American idea versus the charm of the
China
idea and I gave you this review that I
wrote of Martin Jax's book when china
rules the world I just think he's
exaggerating tremendously the ability of
China to to win to influence people
around the world by the the vits vision
for what it stands for certainly the
u.s. brand is profoundly tarnished I
acknowledge that but the Chinese brand i
think is quite weak the nobel peace
prize Tulio shall bow and how China
responded to that were just a
crystallization of how weak the Chinese
brand is so in general I think right now
it's really much too early to say that
China threatens us today but what about
the future and this is my concluding
thing because I want you to have a
chance to raise comments and questions
and redirect me maybe toward issues that
may concern you more if I haven't
addressed those issues yet what about
the future could the continued rise of
China then become a threat to the United
States with really what the debate is
about that's what friedberg is talking
about and it's what Kissinger is talking
about nobody I think and and what Martin
jakes is really talking about is the
future so I of course I say it depends
and it depends on two big things one is
what happens in China the other thing is
what happens in the United States and
both of those are very much open to
debate and very hard to forecast so with
respect to what might happen in China I
think there's a widespread view among
China analysts that the current Chinese
trajectory is very fragile and I think
that many not all but many Chinese feel
that way as well this goes back to what
I was saying before about the insecurity
political and security of the regime at
home it's not a regime that feels very
stable too
to me or I think to Chinese people that
I talk to and I think to the regime
itself I think they feel that they have
to work very hard to stay in power that
if there's bad inflation if there's a
collapse of the job market in China if
people's living standards don't continue
to improve in China at a rapid pace or
if they are humiliated in some
international conflict that the regime
is open to question it's a sharp
contrast with a country like Japan where
the regime has performed very badly for
30 or so years but there's no movement
in Japan really that says let's throw
out the two-party system let's throw out
the Constitution let's bring back the
military let's bring back the fascists
or something that there's but in China
there is a constant debate over what's
the alternative to one-party rule
there's a pro-democracy movement then
the party itself there are people
talking about the need for political
reform of the system how fundam how
thorough a reform is never really made
clear so there's this always this idea
that the current Chinese political
system is in a transition to something
in that it's open to question that's not
found in stable regimes as well the
economic model in China seems to be
fragile this rapid rate of growth the
the danger of overheating the danger
that foreign markets will not be able to
continue to absorb the Chinese growth
model the environmental damage that is
being done by the Chinese growth model
the natural slowdown of growth that any
economy goes through as it matures the
need to shift as cost of labour
increases into higher value-added
products and the question about whether
the Chinese economy can really support
innovation and all these things so
there's so much questioning about that
also so
it seems like the Chinese economy may
slow down the system may encounter some
kind of a political crisis any of those
kinds of scenarios could answer our
question about the Chinese threat by
setting back this threat slowing the
rate of growth damaging the sort of
strategic focus that the Chinese
leadership has been able to sustain in
the last twenty or so more 30 years
could even produce a different kind of
Chinese threat if I'm not saying this is
likely but if the Chinese system really
entered a deep crisis and and began to
in some way collapse there was a book
published to about ten years ago called
the coming collapse of China what the
collapse of China would look like is
there are so many forms that it could
take we don't have time to discuss it
but if it was something like that it
would be that would actually be bad for
the outside world because of the
vastness of this political system so so
the idea that China in the future would
become a threat partly depends on the
internal trajectory of China which is
very questionable and then the second
thing that it depends on i think is
really the the west and and whether we
collapse or decline and and also upon
the policies that we adopt toward China
so I always tell people the best China
policy for the United States is a good
US policy we should fix our problems
that's why I support these kids on Wall
Street I don't know what they want to do
but
no they want to fix the problem yeah oh
you know we gotta fix our economy I mean
I know none of this is easy but this is
what we need to do continue the vitality
of the US and the same thing for Europe
and continued vitality of the u.s.
European Alliance which i think you know
I don't see a threat to that either but
it's very important and and I think that
if the u.s. keeps its lead and I have I
am NOT one of those people who believes
in sort of historical inevitability that
what goes up must come down and since
the US has been in the lead it must
decline i think the US has every
realistic possibility of continuing to
be a leader in innovation in an economic
growth and in military technology and so
on even though it's a moving target so
if we can fix the US and not jump to the
conclusion that china well so that's the
first thing and then I think the wise
handling of China is the second
requirement for US policy which is not
something I can summarize in a word you
know like to handle China we have to do
a Pacific community like Kissinger says
I don't think there's any one model but
I think all the issues having to do with
China whether it's the South China Sea
all the issues where the US and China
interests come into friction I don't
want to say conflict but I think
friction whether it's the freedom of
navigation in the South China Sea which
is a very current and sharp issue of
friction or whether it's the value of
dollar exchange rate or whether it's
Chinese trade policy John or Chinese
human rights policy that the US needs to
find the right balance where we draw the
where we firmly articulate and work for
our interests and on each of these
issues I have my own opinion about what
those fundamental American interests are
while not panicking and threatening the
Chinese interests which I tried to
explain you know what I think that they
are and i believe that fundamentally
American and Chinese security interests
are in theory compatible they don't
represent an inevitable conflict and the
main reason for that is China's over
there and we're over here our security
interests have to do with our region
they extend to the area around China but
the stability of Japan the stability of
Korea freedom of navigation in the South
China Sea actually are in the interests
of both China and the United States
prosperity is in the interests of both
China and the United States and so on so
to at a high level of generality I think
the two countries interests are
compatible but to navigate through the
adjustment of all those interests
without creating a conflict requires
skill which I hope states persons on
both sides will demonstrate and so far i
actually think they have done that so I
the bottom line is I don't see an
inevitable conflict and I use the word
conflict in a strict sense a real
conflict military between China and the
United States coming from the rise of
China partly because China's rise may
not can probably want to continue on
this sharp trajectory and partly because
the u.s. not need not decline and part
because the two sides can work their way
through to finding the common interest
that they have now the point of view
that I am expressing my analysis i think
is not very popular in the US political
system partly because it's too
complicated you know an academic but i
think it's pretty consistent with the
views of the professional policymakers
in the in the government in the United
States and action and so who don't play
the political game so the political game
in the United States is very loud and
very simplified and has is can be
important but there's a quiet substratum
of professional policy-making which
tends to be more stable more balanced it
doesn't mean that we're completely safe
in anybody's hands but but I think what
I'm saying may sound unfamiliar but i
think it's not that I influence the
people in Washington maybe they
influenced me more but I think those who
deal with China as a focus of interest
would often come to a similar something
similar not exactly but something
similar to my point of view so you may
see American China policy under the
surface so for example with the hewing
to this type of line for example with
the currency issue while it's being
debated so loudly in Washington the the
finance professionals on both sides are
actually managing it I think with
understanding of one another's
constraints even though they have to
answer their political people as well
okay so let me stop there